Joston Ramon Theney, Screenwriter, Author,
Director, Producer: I can't take that
advice because it's not a very Hollywood ending
and she tells him well Hollywood ending
all depends on where you stop the story.
Film Courage: What are ways that a writer
can create high stakes for their character?
Joston: Ooh, it's a good question. It has
to be something that relates to their wound.
It has to be some kink in their armor
where this makes it personal for them
it has to be that that's number one and
because overall the story is about them
overcoming that wound and that somehow tying into
this goal of stopping whatever the antagonist is
so but the stakes have to be high enough where it
almost seems insurmountable so yeah I believe that
the stakes are very important but it has to be
all relatable to the character into the audience
okay so if it's something that's too avant-garde
we can't understand it but if it's just sort of
about the basic needs of living safety security
then we can relate to it I think it can be
almost anything it all depends on who
you are who your core audience is for
just giving example for once and one if you if you
watch the film it's it's very easy to sit back and
go I what I don't really get it but the story is
very meta it's it's very meta this there's a story
happening and then there's a story that the writer
is writing but unbeknownst to him they both are
the same story okay and in the story that he's
trying to write that he's having writer's block
with the reason why he can't relate is because
he's cut so many pieces of himself away to fit
in to fit in with this life with his wife this new
Hollywood life he was doing it before when he was
trying to do sales he's just trying to fit in with
everybody with his friends he keeps cutting off
pieces of himself to the point where he doesn't
recognize himself anymore okay and he's not
honest with himself without honesty and he doesn't
know himself he doesn't even know what he wants
he's writing a script that he can't he can't
finish it it seems convoluted there's all
this other stuff going on inside the story that
he's writing is about a guy who's robbing a bank
he wants the money then there's his girl that he
meets inside of the bank he starts falling for
the girl there's the police outside the police are
going to make him pay for whatever he does if he
wants the girl he has to give up the money because
she doesn't like stealing and all that other kind
of stuff if he takes the money he loses the girl
and all of that the police are still outside how
is he going to get past that in both of these
stories it's not even knowing what the guy wants
the guy doesn't know what he wants he's all
over the place and what you begin to realize
is for the protagonist and the story his wife
is really related to the money in the story
that's his security he's so secure
with his wife because she's on a sole
property she makes lots of money he can be
a struggling writer and it doesn't matter
so he has that in the movie that's money that's
security and then he meets this girl named Pia
and he's completely infatuated by her it's
exciting and it's new well that's the girl in
the story it's exciting and it's new he's always
needed money and security but excitement has
taken over does he choose excitement and then of
course the woman's husband who's his best friend
is the police that's the people who
are going to hold him accountable
they're going to he's going to he's going to
have to suffer a consequence whether it's good
or bad he's gotta suffer a consequence that
friend is going to make him pay he's making
him pay the whole movie when you're watching
you're just like geez you almost considered
the friend to be the bad guy until you realize
this guy has a wife but he's infatuated with
this other woman and that's the dance
that is going on in this entire film
so I look at it and I go the film may be hard
to understand it may be hard to understand
how to relate to it and how this relates
to you but for a specific group of people
they'll understand that desire to fit in and
that you don't even know yourself and that you're
driven by what you want in the moment but do you
even really want it do yourself enough to know you
really want it and I think there is a segment of
audiences that can relate but then they'll also be
a segment that'll say I don't even get any of this
it's because they don't relate to any of it they
just don't but that movie's not for them sure or
maybe they've seen that in someone close to them
or or they used to be that and then they realize
all that's empty but but I see what you mean
someone that's really conflicted they want what
they want they're willing to kind of sell their
soul for it yeah yeah I think that's a that's a
good story to write about Hollywood mm-hmm it is
and it's him he's he's he's he's just in the
wind because he doesn't know himself anymore
sure he doesn't how long did it take you to
write the script I started writing it in probably
2017-2018 I started writing it but
it was one of those ones where I just
kind of plugged away at it for a little bit at
a time and then I got to a point where I said
I don't know where I should take this story and
then what happened was I put it aside for a moment
and I went off and I did some other work and
it was around that time that I realized man
the reason why I didn't know where to go
with this story was because I was trying to
stick a Hollywood ending on it and it's
funny because that's actually a line
in the earlier in the script is that he was saying
he's taking advice from the character p and he
says I can't take that advice because it's not
a very Hollywood ending and she tells them well
Hollywood ending all depends on where you stop the
story and so I said to myself I have to be honest
in the rest of the screenplay I have to
be honest and I have to make him have
real conversations about where he's headed where
his relationships are headed where his life is
headed he has to have these real conversations
now he can't have them the way that we have them
but he has to have them and he has to make a
decision it can't be ambiguous he has to make
a decision and so once I went back into the script
with that mandate I was able to wrap it up pretty
quickly I was going to wrap it pretty quickly and
pretty honestly and with as much truth as possible
and did you give the script to many people for
feedback no no I think feedback is great sometimes
but when it's something that's very it was very
new for me to be that honest and that truthful
and not try to stick like Hollywood stuff
into it Hollywood magic to make it magically
resolve I didn't want that type of feedback
I wanted I wanted it to exist for what it was
so you didn't need to get notes from
anybody because you self-financed it
and so you just knew you were but were
there any parts that maybe were unclear
that you wanted people to see and flesh out for
the characters or no you just knew we were going
to do it this one way I knew I was going to do
it that one way what I did was once I got actors
on board who were very very talented and they
were very outspoken about their own thoughts on it
I was able to just have a conversation with
them where I said free like there are no
wrong answers okay but we're just going to sit
down and we're going to talk about the script
and we're going to talk about the moments and
how we can make them honest and very truthful
so let's have those conversations and like I said
it was very productive because no one was saying
but I think it should end this way or I think
I should do I established very early on the
theme of the movie and where it's headed is not
changing how we get there may adjust a little bit
but where this train is headed it already left
the station and it's headed to this destination
so we all sat down and we said okay cool
in these moments here are things that we
can do to make it more truthful and make it feel
more honest and that's really what we focused on
so there were some changes along
the way but for the most part
what was on the page was on the screen for the
most part I got I got very very close I would say
I would say I was 75 there 75 of what I wanted is
on the screen which is a high number for me what
do you tell other screenwriters filmmakers about
being too precious about certain scenes that maybe
they just don't totally serve the story
I haven't had to have that conversation
however that conversation was had with
me and it was had by Eddie Watkins
he told me he said your biggest problem is
that you're married to everything you do
you can't be that way especially if you're not the
one financing and directing it you can't be things
are going to have to change for whatever reason
and you're going to have to be open to making
whatever those changes are work and that's what I
would tell anybody who's treating it too precious
so because we all like want
certain scenes or some little
the artifact in the film and it means
something to us but the audience might not care
and and so when people have given you those
notes or maybe it was just ed are you open to
changing them or has it been hard for you to take
notes and to remove certain things in the past
I would say I was probably more open to
removing it even if I didn't agree I’d remove it
because I want this issue to die and I don't
want things to keep carrying over or whatever but
once I started to just kind of stand up and say
this is this is my film even if you pay for it
it's my film because ultimately nobody's going
to say well I looked at this movie that producer
must have been great that's not what they're
going to say they're going to say the director
and the writer and the cast were great that's
what they're going to say and if people know a
little bit more about the industry they're
going to say the cinematographer was great
but what they're not going to say is wow that
producer really knows his stuff that just doesn't
happen and so what happened is is that we made
the film and we always understood what it was
supposed to be and then as we got further along
people's ego started to get involved and even
though I would explain I understand that this is
great for you but we're at service to the story
not to you so the person would relent and so as
we got further into editing the conversations
would come up again well I think we should
really add this and I’m like you're serving
your own ego you're not really serving the
story so no I don't think we should do that
and so we would go have a little bit back
and forth until I would just say okay what
just so we can be done with it and then you
would cut it and before it it was a movie
that was granted at 2 hours and 15 minutes
it's a bit long so we we cut it down to about
maybe an hour 45 minutes so now it's
cut down only that needs to happen is
color and a little bit of sound work and it's
ready to be done so I handed off and ultimately
I heard through the grapevine that the film was
finished and that it was at an hour and a half
that's really weird it's really weird
something and it was because I have to take
accountability and responsibility I handed
off the film along with all the footage
so that it could have the finishing touches put
on it and what ultimately happened was this person
decided to put all these scenes back in and remove
all these other scenes so that their work would
stand out a bit more and it was an ego thing and I
said what I dropped the ball on that one because I
gave that person the ability to do it that was
that was my fault and it'll never happen again
it'll never happen again because that film floats
around and people say wow that film and I can't
take I can't take credit for the good or the bad
because it's not my film it's not and that was
because I started in the beginning we talked about
the tv show 24 and Jack Bauer and the guy says ah
you've never done anything bad you've never made
a bad decision you've never just done this one
little thing and he says no because once you do
that one little thing it makes it easier to do
the second thing and the third thing and that
one thing that I did was that I compromised and
I did it just so that the conversation would
die I said ah just and I gave in a little
and a little bit more and a little bit more and
then eventually the film completely changed and
I said I just won't allow that to happen again if
I do work with someone else the film that they'll
receive to do any type of finishing touches which
by the way I’ll do them all in house so that when
I hand it off it's a finished film but let's just
say that I had to end it off they would only get
the film to work with and that would be it because
it's my responsibility to make sure that we're
honest to the film and what the film is trying to
say we're in service of the film not to our egos.
What do you like about this video?